Welcome to our fictional
company Twisted Threads.
Twisted Threads ships
cotton t-shirts on demand.
The founder started the company ten
years ago from her basement, but
it has since expanded
to over 200 employees.
There is a warehouse, several physical
stores, and an e-commerce site.
Customers love the high quality
materials and custom designs.
That's the good news.
Now for the bad news.
[SOUND] Twisted Threads has a homegrown
inventory system separate for
each physical shop and the warehouse.
The demand varies per season in both
the quantity of t-shirts ordered and
the type of items that customers want.
Because of this, the company has
supply and inventory issues.
Sometimes the company
runs out of stock and
customer order fulfillment is
delayed by a week or more.
[SOUND] At other times,
Twisted Threads has ordered way too
many T-shirts from its supplier.
They have had to throw out
merchandise to make room for
newer more popular styles.
Twisted Threads hosted servers for their
Internet shop in-house, but there was
massive flooding in the city and their
servers were damaged beyond repair.
[SOUND] They decided
to move to the cloud.
Since making this decision, there have
been major issues with performance and
cost on the cloud.
Customers complain about
the website being buggy.
The site has gone down several times
during periods of high traffic
like the holiday season.
[SOUND] The product team
wants more features, but
the rollout of new features
is painfully slow.
The competition just launched
personalization on their site,
which was a huge hit with customers.
Twisted Threads is falling behind
because their website is outdated.
Developers are unhappy because
deployment of new features
takes ages and operations does
not give them new servers.
Operations is too overwhelmed with
running the cloud in general and
worry about what will happen if
the cloud data center burns down.
[SOUND]